good evening so we are back again and
today the team is the greatest loss it's
all okay
I can also call it like the most painful
losses well this one which I'm going to
delete happens like relatively a long
time ago but it was quite an interesting
one I haven't got back to to take a look
at this game for quite a few years and
they lot of extra story connected with
with this game first of all it was my
last one in Piatt it was in Istanbul in
year 2000 it was the fraud to Olympia
take place for the Bulgarian team and I
have to be honest with you this was the
only Olympiad in each I especially
prepared for this will impede I mean all
the other three are impaired I had to
play other tournaments all the time so I
didn't have like a special preparation
for this event and Olympiad in my
opinion are the toughest events because
they are team events you have to play
quite responsibly but also you never
know I mean which route you're going to
play it's a very tough schedule and also
you look at your colleagues and our team
was almost always playing with most of
the other best teams but particularly
this Olympiad in the in year 2000 there
were a lot of a lot of things connected
with only get an especially with our
with our Bulgarian team so the coaching
our team the notorious serial Denis of
the manager of our best chess player the
actual champion the same two paths he
made even before the the beginning of
the leap yet some let's call them
interesting decisions I will we were
living in Spain I was living in Spain he
was living in Spain also with tupelov so
he contacted me we agree that I'm going
to play at least 10 games which I did in
the first 11 rounds ok we had like a
contract
everything was clear but then in our
team and the selection our team was
quite filled because for the first time
and tonight to stefanova played for our
team this is the ex women world champion
and she's incredibly talented and very
good but okay maybe this was not the
moment because she could have played for
the women's team and they had a you know
a very good team but he somehow chose to
to take and try to play in the men's
team not too many games okay there were
very special circumstances and when I
when I'm talking with you about
preparing for this Olympia yes for this
will impede I had some time to prepare
even I prepared a new opening in this
new opening was the French defence which
I always consider and I still consider
it a difficult opening I mean you have
to know it's very very well to feel
comfortable in many of these positions
with less space with a lot of suffering
so I never was fount of the French
defense and I know it quite well because
there was a fellow Grandmaster from my
hometown in Bulgaria bloody melting
trough who played all his life
French so I was able to look at his
analysis and his experiences but I
always felt very comfortable with the
white side of the French but just have
like a new opening because although this
was year 2000 the computers were
starting to influence the game not like
today but still you have to prepare well
and it's like a good idea for such a
responsible tournament to play like a
new opening although my choice of French
probably was the wrong one it did fairly
well at this Olympia this was the only
loss against one of the most talented
players in the world scene still today
which took I consider him an incredible
player very talented we're cooking this
time was a great specialist of the
English attack against Nidal and neither
was my main weapon and it made it
throughout the whole of my create
certainly quite well so I knew that if I
play a night off against be cook is
going to play the English attack and
with a little bit of havoc
I started this game playing the French
and it was not surprised that he played
against me the advanced variation
because if you just check his the
results many many pluses against the the
French in indecision transpiration of
course he plays analyzed - oh yeah we
started with he for a 6 d 4 D 5 e 5 C 5
the normal moves Bishop d7 Bishop e2
this was expected and now I just get one
idea which I which I played in this game
this was probably prepared before that
ok it was like almost 19 years ago so
I'm not very sure of all the details but
I remembered the idea with 96-97
champagne in this game was somewhat
analyzed you know in the months before
the tournament so ok it was not like a
big surprise to me but I always felt not
very sure the ended perspiration and I
have some memory in when I was in the in
the military I played with a player
which I was clearly a much stronger and
I paint with black this line I played
with Queen b6 instead of Bishop d7 Queen
b6 a 3 C 4 just like the image of my
colleague from my hometown grandma
seemed of used to play and we got
absolutely close position and I couldn't
win I mean it was completely closed
position and these you know bad
experience from playing in this relation
you know always remained in my in my
head so this time I want to play a
little bit more in a more flexible way
so I didn't want to play like Queen b6
and I played with Bishop d7 I have
prepared quite a risky align this with
f6 well it's also considered like one of
the main lines although one of the
greatest specialists of French sakis
because here there are comments his
comment ok his commencing in year 2000
so there there are some mistakes there
are some manipulation which are not
exactly true but for me it was quite
interesting
to share with you also a very good
player how he thought about this game he
played French of his life so he's not
very fount of the of the move f6 but I
will I want to play it like more
dynamically and I'm very far away from
being a specialist from the black site
and the French know so I played the f6
here he is more fun to play in 97 they
take 95 like playing with less space but
more solidly so maybe it's much more to
subtract his taste but it was not my
intention in this game so castle and ok
if you now take only 5 there was even a
game plating in this will impute we're
not going to take them take a look but
away it looks quite too risky because if
you play let me just give you one
example like take take take
Bishop c6 well c4 like they played in
this game just to play like an
interesting pawn structure it's not the
only the only way I'm kind of a don't
like when I'm not developing my PC so
this is the kind of tuition which I
think that White has a lot of charges
some of them dynamic some of the
position like in this game they play it
right with with c4 trying you know to
put knight on c3 maybe I need to block
the patient with d4 then of course they
have a opposition with more space in a
in a clear square on e4 - you know
transport their pieces so I'm not very
fond of this position so it's no
surprise that here I chose Queen b6 a
more dynamic and oh he surprised me I
was not like I told you very
well-prepared about this position but he
surprised me with 93 nowadays I think it
probably you know taking on c5 b4 like
let me show you here on the broad I
killed before an hour playing even for
some kind of a blockade not wanting too
much of advantage like Bishop a4 or
playing c4 very aggressively now try to
open the game before black has finished
his development and here you can see on
the broad some of its inconveniences so
the bishop on e7
takes like this square from the knight
Knight has to go to h6
maybe play 7n castle so this is like
black need a little bit of time they're
not doing bad in the in the in the
center but they need some time and if
the position is open now when White King
is very safe it can be dangerous for
them so here T voice is interesting
no Bishop f4 is more more positional but
away probably this would have been not
very comfortable for me but we should
choose Knight e3 public was familiar
with this approach but at least what I
knew about this mission is that I like
this plan just to take here and to play
90-second to put it on epsilon because
the pollution of the night on XM gives
me more flexibility it controls the g5
square the bishop can go to e7 and then
okay depending on the circumstances you
can cast off short or like in this game
you can castle along well in this game I
had to Castle long because immediately
he follows with c4 here if you look at
this patient with a computer cost he'll
recommend here to push be evil but on
before it was not my attention talk on
the game because of a when I still have
not finished my development I'm not keen
to open the game so out get played
knight of seven how good is the potion I
have my doubts but I remember it I would
get played here night itself
he has like a more sharp approach see
for now d4 Bishop d3 97 rookie one well
now he has like a good control of the
center the knight is going to t2 and in
order you know not to be to get in a
position with less space and not much
counter play I think at I'm obliged here
to castle castle long because then the
patient on my knight on f7 and the
possibility to push some pause on the
King side gives me counter place no I'm
going to be stuck with a similar
position like one game which is given
earlier here you can see even play to
the same a little bit with a clear
positional advantage because okay then
when the night is on f7 and I hit castle
shot I can start pushing pawns in front
of my King know
and I'll be just clearly worse so this
is the idea of the night on essay on it
if we can make it like a sharper sharper
position so Bishop e7 h 4 this is purely
a prophylactic move now and of course
it's no problem if you Castle if you
cast off short because if you Castle
short okay KITT place 92 this pawn h4
restricts the black pieces and also
sometimes in can be used just for going
into attack on the on the King side if
the the black King height on the King
side but the black King does not have an
intention to hide on the on the King
side and here sakis here's one
suggestion which I really do not
understand it very well so he says night
before Bishop b4 and now to Castle short
well to Castle short it's possible to
three plays Knight c2n everything which
I said before stands I mean in my
opinion white has a clear positional
advantage he has more space basically
it's very difficult to understand where
it's blacks counter play and this
especially for us humans we need to have
you know some clear play we need to know
what we are doing we just can't stand
without space and you know suffering and
this is not the idea away maybe some
experts a French taking some for a
longer time but as I've been almost all
my life like a cilium play and also
Spanish player I don't like this kind of
a you know suffering for a long time I
gotta have like it's my phrase I like
like three results on the board I don't
like to have like this passive position
with two possible results you know you
make a draw you lose so this is not like
my kind of thing so I make here a long
caso 92 and he is very interesting to
see what sakis says about the pollution
not taught to put some critical sockets
because of it sakis he liked to look at
the game he was not familiar with
circumstances and he thought if you look
at this game without knowing anything
you'll see this you know just Chris
Chuck just crushed you know
the blacks position he made like a very
good attack and everything is is clear
no sakis caught some of the have the
moments quite quite right at the game
some of them he missed them but he
didn't have much time and this was
probably not the only game he looked
but I can give you some some interesting
perspectives so now he says
unfortunately for black the residence of
the his King is much more insecure and
blacks counterplay probably will be
allayed well this it may seem C so if
you look at the game but it's quite far
away from the from the truth so here I
felt that my question was it was very
good and quite interesting I have seen
that if you place what what followed in
the game it was you know no no problem
for me but there were some special
circumstances and I repeat it's not an
excuse it just giving you the facts
which because we humans can effect you
doing in the real game and may be okay
like I told you probably this was like
the ninth game I played I don't remember
which was my off day but it is possible
so you've got tired only bit and you may
not feel you know like physically tired
but when you start making some
inexplicable things and mistakes maybe
your nervous system is starting to get a
little bit tired in this very strong and
very responsible events like the chess
fling build so here I played rugby eight
and quite unexpectedly even for me but
because okay I was very not not happy
that I I couldn't play an or denial
I couldn't get access to some some of
these analysis so I told my question is
is very good and here are very bad
psychological move and very untypical
for me I very rarely have offered jaws
I'm not very fond of offering jaws but
here because I thought that my question
is is good I'm threatening you know just
to play g5 he's attack on the on the
queenside I have seen that it's not
really going to happen I couldn't see
how it's going to make it and that's why
I refer to jaw
and I thought it okay here is this I'm
going to get to have some roast anger
should probably also think that his
mission is is nothing special and this
is to put it mildly
I told it and black has a a good
position now it was quite surprised to
me that he didn't answer anything which
is quite all right but this is also I'm
not sure if it was like psychological
move but sometimes you know chess
players maybe in the past maybe nowadays
too they pretend this if you if they
don't hear you so you know sometimes
there was some case I've read in the
book that you know I didn't do that of
course but sometimes they have to repeat
the offer and they say I didn't hear you
some now and all he plays the move so
this is like can put you in a some kind
of an awkward situation and he for me it
was a surprise and I got you know this
is like which this detail shows that
you're tired if you became of this very
small team nervous and when he played
his move a tree well I not only forgot
what what I want to play but I started
you know to play very fast and this is
like a legend when not only you had like
a easy move because okay you this is the
very natural way to stop his play
because he's threatening before so I
have seen that in that before candid on
on a tree you can place as Queen b3 and
it's not easy for him you know he needs
a lot of time and this time we will be
used you know to get your counter play
with g5 so still today I don't have an
explanation why I didn't played a Queen
b3 it's a very natural way it was why I
offered him a job because I thought that
my position is is fine in just before
showing your a3 just to show that it was
not like possible to transpose the move
role just to play before and after you
take to open the the Queen side oh it
will be like great for white but I play
a five in steel you need time because on
a tree are FB 3 you know b3 and if you
go back out play a four so it
a clear way how you can open the the
queenside so after a three it was
absolutely necessary to play Queen b3
and that's why I put on g5 a question
mark no because it's such a bad move
because even if he takes from g5 you
could have played Queen b3 but wait if I
just beyond played here it mean it can't
be you know starting to lose control
so you're becoming nervous and this
happens in you're starting playing I
start to play very fast as if I was you
know furious that he the intercept draw
which was the most natural thing in the
world because this one important imagine
only just she was absolutely right you
know so this was a very interesting
detail but it influenced the whole game
because after that he continued to play
normal moves the pigeon was still a
complex one all right my play was like
somebody who was doomed so instead of
playing Queen b3 I played g5 which does
not pay attention to his obvious play on
the Queen side and it's a receipt for
disaster although the position or he
takes on g5 kill Queen b3 is possible
but away I take on on g5 Bishop takes on
g5 he keeps his knight on f3 because his
knight on f3 can be included even on the
under attack of the of the black King
because when he plays before even the
pawn on d4 becomes a problem and okay to
open small house against the black King
know if you I repeat if you look at the
whole game it seems like you know
everything that I did is very easy and
very natural but there were a couple of
very big mistakes so b4 like
sake says and okay there is no dispute
about that a very easy move which you
made by the head oh yes but it could
have been prevented no so remember these
prophylactic measures when you sometimes
you can take so here it was like a
glitch great negligence not not to play
like a perfect move like Queen b3 it's
not like out of this world
you just prevent you know the openers
play so be
for Bishop e7 o Bishop e7 is also like a
bad move
we it keeps wasting time and of course
this is like a sharp positioning you can
afford this luxury it is better really
to play and this was a suggestion by by
Chucky's Ruby g7 and then to double the
rooks and although it seems like he's
having the initiative there were some
mistakes which probably in the in the
year 2020 computers were not so good but
I really think it's not about the
strength of the computers I think it
here position which he gave like this
one like he gave it it's a clear
advantage in my opinion you don't need a
computer see that if you take here and
loop tation g3 it doesn't matter what
the computer gives and I've checked it
today and the computer says that black
has a winning position by the way let's
forget about that because the computers
may say many things but one thing is
obvious you have an attack or you can
include the Queen you can include even
the bishop for me eight oh it's
difficult here to play this with with
why oh I don't know why PUC is also sure
but ok this of course this is not the
first line we can play differently with
a wheat white but still rook g7 and just
you know trying to get your play going
is the right way to go but ok here I
kept lost control of the game which you
can see from the the moves to follow and
I play Bishop e7 Bishop e4 he just puts
all hippies on the right squares and to
play this game from the white side is
much easier because we play rootbeer on
Bishop e4 and you know you try to open
kiss King which basically is not not so
difficult now I gave here detection
before a bad movement and yet it's a
it's a bad book although it's not easy
to suggest you know like a really good
move here because it's much easier to
play with white but still opening the
position I I don't like it maybe
something else could have been tried
like rubgy for only there is one detail
that when the rooks on g4 sometimes it
goes into the attack from the Queen no
detection see if I should be one taken
d4 so there is this detail
but still there should be something
better than detection before I mean just
it seems like I'm fighting with the with
the fire with two with a gas which
basically everybody knows is not a very
good idea so I take on b4
he takes from b4 and Knight takes from
people well if I take with the with the
bishop on before he takes takes from d4
basically okay the attack is is going by
itself so here I play this move Bishop
taken before and now it's quite
interesting that although the whole game
looks like you know very natural play
easy win the next move is quite great if
it's not the best move objectively but
it's interesting and it has to do it
when a great talent is pear although
it's not so clear he opens more lines
because he thinks that this is the right
approach
technically probably not the best move
because route B one here the Queen goes
out of the pin and Knight takes d4
probably is much more unpleasant because
the attack here is very very strong so
if you look at this the main detail is
it he's attacking with almost all of key
species and you can take a knife because
the Queen goes to a fight no this is the
very the very important detail but I was
really surprised here by g5
although I thought that c5 was also good
during the game really I was not happy
about seeing c5 also I thought it
through b1 is quite unpleasant but c5
may be objectively I'm good but you know
you can imagine yourself in in my shoes
I was very depressed by you know not
playing the moves I wanted to play and
now he's opening all the lies against
meaning he's attacking me and it's much
more difficult to defend them to attack
now
sometimes in this mission and especially
with so many open alliance to attack is
more natural you can easier find
resources and especially such talented
player like we took and defending here
and it's one of the pair I have to
mention to you so very few players and I
can name you one legendary play on
Polikarpov take it this is special
talent so Karpov had two very special
features not only he's a legendary
player but one of his features was that
when he was at his best in he was it is
best for many many years at the end of
the game
he started to play like nowadays cousin
he started to play even even better so
four hours of the game has passed many
of the players had a little bit tired
now they started to make mistake and
they that is if they are putting another
gia and it's time to play even even with
a better quality and this is this is
bringing a lot of points so keropok has
this habit and another one which has to
do it with this game as with my comment
Karpov and this is like a little bit
like the super heroes this feature so
imagine that Karpov is playing and game
and you are pressing him you have an
advantage against him like for four
hours his rows you keep pressuring he
keeps defending and he defended very
well because he calculated this short
lines with incredible precision
he kept later with incredible precision
so he could defend very stubbornly so
after four hours you're still a little
bit better but he can't defend it and
okay in one moment you say okay I can do
anything more it will be like a draw so
the pigeon is Yuko and you think that
like many many players after such a
tough defense are going to be happy and
many players are happy no car pocket and
not only couple but very few players
have this quality you can't adjust to
forget what was in the past and his that
started to play the patient is an equal
portion like nothing happened before
like he never defended and he is fresh
as a cucumber and he starred in play and
and this special quality also brought
him a lot of a lot of points and did it
just you know just this is exactly what
the engines do they don't have memory of
what has been before but we humans most
of us like the humans we have you know
this memory of what was before so here
probably also I was influenced by ok I
could get played early a better move now
I'm and
peg I've played really bad and this had
to do it with the player played so c5
Bishop taken see fight well this is
actually the only move I mean no doubt
about it
I was quite surprised to see that here
sakis told it maybe and black can play
Queen c7 but after taking here I mean
you don't need to calculate much here no
I mean the black king is completely
alone in you don't need neither
computers not anything I mean this is
just just bad I didn't even consider
that I mean it looked very bad so we
should take on g5 only move rugby one
and now really he goes sakis this is
serious miss a but in my opinion is just
incredible blunder I mean you have to
play your only move here without any
doubt but I I don't have a recollection
if I considered the only move we should
be I probably yes but for some reasons I
was already in some kind of a mood that
probably the position is bad so you have
to play here Bishop b5 the only move and
after Bishop d3 because ok if he if he
tries something more complex like they
in 92 you can even have time to play d3
and the bishop and see if I can start in
or influencing the game so Bishop here a
6 and although ok he has the a line he
looks to have some play well this
patient of the Queen 3 B 4 is not clear
at all the computers even ho-ho this
pigeon well for for human player is
still kind of a not so easy to play but
again you Kara
two extra pawns well the bishop is not
probably great but away the king will
not get a checkmate only on one line
because ok if you gather on the a line
then after check on the edge the king
will go to c7 so not not so clear no not
so clear at all now this is just one one
line but I didn't want to to give your
lines I just want you to have like the
picture when you are playing the game so
you have to play this because there is
nothing
so no doubt about that ambition before
practically is the end of the game in my
opinion although it was a long time ago
it has to do with some big calculation
mistake I think it after like queen Seto
I probably miss get credit on on Bishop
t6 this very simple rotation before
because even after Queen c2 although
this is probably better but this patient
in my opinion should be lost I mean this
one I also don't have any any doubt
about it it looks very bad I mean I
don't have doubt I mean have to to run
here with a king but in my opinion it
was the the bad the really terrible
lemon also Bishop b4 no after that
in my opinion it has to do with a
mistake on the on the bishops e6 so this
is where something went completely wrong
and of course okay
I never considered to be a to be divine
and okay he's the one giving you
checkmate and you're walking you know
through the the chessboard you know some
kind of a trend so so Bishop g6 yeah he
says here I don't remember what package
says but my command is this this see the
simple oversight but it has to do with
some simple mistake probably in some of
the line of Kitty Kotik I miss like a
simple move maybe Ruby well okay so take
take rook takes from before and maybe I
missed just simple after King b8 if you
play King b8 that he'll play just you
know
Queenie for although here it's not about
Miss I mean you you are really feeling
bad in this moment of the game because
okay you don't need to calculate here
just to feel that you know your king is
going to get checkmated so this is like
you know already the the position is is
beyond any salvation so I played here
route d1 and okay here I got checkmate
it and this was my only loss in this
ruling yet but it was a good one
I mean it was like a completely
devastating well for our
good luck we were able we are able to to
win the match because to power one iting
against halluf man and who wears one we
won two and a half one and a half
against Russia well the last time I've
met because I've played the first time
in 94
it was tupelov you can see this game
it's quite impressive to power gave
checkmate to Kasparov with two rocks on
the on the seventh rank in twenty
something moves George if lost against
kramnik in some very long slave spots of
one incredible game in French in French
against Rev so French is not he is not
easy but you have to know it very well
and I was better with black against
people and he offer to join we were
winning the match and yeah dress what
were lost against spasso and the third
pot and I made a draw with the sweedler
in the second time in 98 I think I
played with white well this was the only
time I played with white against begins
and this was like a much easier game we
won I think 301 and IV the instruction
of the coach which was again Daniel
force you play against begins if solid
and this was not difficult because we
need to place the slab so it all right
we played some kind of a slightly better
position for white but okay if this kind
of instruction owner on a team match
when you are with white against solid
players begins if are not not too too
difficult of course away you can always
help over way I was quite happy to to
hear such an instruction this was in 98
so did this game in this checkmate iosef
was really something to remember it was
a painful loss but the next one which
I'm going to show you was I still even
today when I had a recollection of this
game I still can't believe that that
this happened and there are some
circumstances which made this
loss against a colleague of mine a
Bulgarian Grandmaster who is a very
original player very talented the
circumstances of the next game are quite
interesting and it makes the loss
painful not only because the patient was
completely completely winning and
they're very interesting things to take
from this game was just not to that to
repeat this kind of a many many mistakes
but also it was a very important game it
was a qualification match in the great
team championship and if I have won this
game we would our team would have
classified in the Premier League which
we didn't in the in the next in the next
year which I want a very good game I
also against the Bulgarian Grandmaster
in the last in the in the decisive round
yeah against Nicole grandma's Nico so
yeah but this game okay I had everything
you know everything in my in my hand
anyway if you fell in in such moment
it's really difficult okay I'm going to
show you the game because the game
speaks for itself even today when I had
memories of this game it's very it's
very painful because every one of us has
lost like position with big advantage
but there were so many circumstances
which I had to go and I have to be one
thing which I wanted to take from this
game not to be practical not to be like
like I did in the in the last phases of
of the game so when you have many many
choices just try to be to be practical
you'll see at the end of the game and
when you have you can choose between
giving checkmate or having a completely
one end game going to the end game
because something may happen it may not
be a checkmate you can have a mirage in
the completely won in game nothing is
going to happen but okay when there are
more piece on the board even you know
even it looks improbable but you see
that it happened so I was with you know
with black and after tea for the first
move well I'll give you some explanation
because after c4 I didn't play to me at
Levi I like to play the position with
like the reversed dragon I like to place
and position with black against e4
which black fights for space so I like
to play the reverse dragon Oh like t4 if
I dare like the reverse Sicilian snow
with the tempo down but at least you're
always playing for space so it's the
kind of opening taste you have but here
I didn't play e5 because I didn't want
in some of the lines of the reverse
dragon to give me an option to put this
night not on c3 but indeed oh okay I
just you know if I played night f cking
he plays 93 how to have played evite so
I was not avoiding the English which I
usually play but I'm trying a little bit
you know to to give him less choice just
not to be very flexible well of course
it didn't make any difference because he
has prepared another scheme
I couldn't have an idea what he has
prepared but after few moves I already
have an idea probably what was not
waiting for me
so 96 because I we have played quite a
few games in in Bulgaria in individual
champ and I repeat this is a rather
talented grandmaster with the very
original style so it always a pleasure
to play with him 96 93 well now we I
already knew that it's going to be some
kind of a DNA game because in the
Queen's Gambit I played the the Vienna
variation and why I see Knight f3
obviously has prepared some line what
line well during the the first moves you
starting to get like a somewhat an idea
about the other way you don't get you
don't know for sure
well tabash was not never a great
theoretician oh he was not preparing
like deeply but all for this game
probably had like a week or a little bit
more time so even after the game I
didn't ask him but I think I had an idea
what was prepared so ii 6 d 4 D 5 and
after Bishop g5 already this fourth move
I knew that he didn't want just to play
the normal Vienna lines which starts
with 93 details you see for the via
narration of the Queens Queens gambit
accepted which I played for a long long
time
so obviously he wants on a not so
popular line a gambit line but but the
pipe interesting on with an item veto
because okay there is no need to play
Bishop defied Bishop before a 93 if you
can play 93 you're not avoiding anything
so when you see Bishop g5 I was already
had an idea that maybe around a few
moves after that and new ideas he's
waiting for me and yes he had an idea
although probably this time I was a
little bit able to surprise him a little
bit earlier but not to it something
prepared simply I was quite quite
familiar with this type of position so
this is what helped me in this game in
in the opening phase so we should be g5
we should be 492 this was his idea
details here Quincy to b5 now the
inclusion of this moves a 496 now you'll
see the whole idea to include a 4 and T
6 is when he takes from f6 not to be
able to take with the Queen because of
the change from b5 you have query for
Queen even in the rukon p8 has problems
and again I was aware about that so
that's why he includes here a a for this
I wanted to explain to you so a for c6
and now he takes on f6 an engine of this
prevents Queen takes on f6 the way it
has also some obvious handicap because
when you exchange a dark squared bishop
you take a lot of responsibility
you make the black pawn structure worse
but okay the bishop the dark squared
bishop in that control of all these
complex of squares the dark is very very
important and you have already
sacrificed the pawns you have to be sure
you know to get like a real compensation
something which didn't happen in this
game so take g3 we should be 7 Bishop g2
97 caso and here is what I thought that
he has prepared before the game because
here it was played before
ASIC
anyway a game which I slightly
remembered I had some doubt that YK has
a kind of a interesting pleasure
composition but during the game I taught
here for 20 minutes
and I couldn't see why I should play a 6
when I can make the bishop on b4 even
stronger with a natural move like a 5
and this was all over the broad because
I like I told you I was familiar with
this type of pushin so I made this
annuity and after some years after that
it was even played by the the seconds of
- and now the very well famous grand
must avoid touch it if I feel ok after
that black get very good result in his
vision so probably disappeared the whole
portion so this was another - over the
broad well nothing extraordinary simply
I think the whole whites idea is nothing
special so a 5 over the Bob which gives
you more space and especially the Bishop
from b7 cannot not only be you know
close to behind the his pawns but he has
chance you know to get him to play how
he can gain to play well he has to to
push here b3 and after the exchange you
have more dynamic options so you can
take on a foreign play Bishop e6 Bishop
e5 you can play 96 oh you can play like
in the game one idea which has to do
with a Catalan ideas which you've seen
in the in the Catalan opening which here
is no no surprise at all so I played he
played b3 they take castle now later I
think here they even played immediately
B takes from a4 and Bishop a6
immediately activating you know the
bishop now it may be some but I think
that my move for the first try is quite
alright so castle and ok now of course
because you have not only more space for
your pieces but the pawn on e5 is well
protected so he doesn't care any kind of
this beaucoup Indian ideas just to take
on b5
95 and to take your Bishop because ok
there is nobody here now you play rock
a7 there is no pause on a6 which are
hanging so the black pawns and
under attack in the porn a5 clearly
gives you more space so no motives like
a Texan be fight night because you just
keep you know taking the night and you
play okay seven and okay everything is
is good because on the dark squares
you are the master on the light squares
basically there is nobody to attack so
look everyone looking for some
positional compensation and now this is
a well-known Catalan idea and it has to
do of course with the getting more space
with the right idea a five because if
the pawn is on a six and you play the
following move through k7o it will be a
little bit ridiculous
but now it makes sense no because I'll
play Queen e8 and then now I'm ready to
play Hotel just to open the game and I'm
playing here where he can sacrifice the
pawned basically on the quiz right I'm
carrying you know probably passed pawns
and it it even you know with the course
of the game it even over passed all of
my hopes but here I thought it after the
opening I have a clear advantage so no
doubt about it and his next move I'm not
going to go into detail he could have
played something else but I still think
that this person is is clearly much
easier to play with with black and his
composition is is very very symbolic but
his next move just proved it you know he
has real doubts about his play and he
just plays a move just to try to show it
maybe he can some compensation but away
here nobody after the next move can can
try to to give me a feeling it after
move like h4 you have a compensation so
do you just a move which clearly shows
that okay something is wrong with white
Persian so they are trying somehow you
know not to do more damage to his
position in a waiting for you to make
mistakes which here for a long time
didn't happen so I kept playing some
quite logical moves let me show you I
played here Queenie 791 no trying at
least you know to put an item d3 to get
some positional concession 96
so you're pressing on a four and now he
has to open the pigeon the way he opens
the position then your extra pond and
the past ponds on the queenside
and basically I'm going to aside the
game and still you have the question
where is exactly white computation for
editing 96 now if it takes on c6 let me
show us not many lies in this in this
game the the most important lines and
when that the tragedy happened at the
end so if he takes here you take and
okay you have a pair a pair of bishops
no and probably giving you know a lot of
damage to the black pigeon this is
probably you know as good as reasonable
so if you place like 95 you can just
take it
94 rook b8 anyway I mean here I don't
see he doesn't have any squares where to
put his pieces so you have to pawn
switch any endgame inside immediately
anyone you can get this kind of a that's
why I show this kind of a typical
typical tactics no it takes them on c5
you play room d1 this is like the weak
background no rook d1 and after he goes
away you're taken this this rook here is
hanging yeah not but okay the pollution
is very good for for black so he takes
and this should be like a technical
position no I mean and that's why I
think that I've played it quite quite
well let us follow 93 roots yet with a
temple and the more moves you can make
in a good patient we attempt oh well
everything is going very good so 95 well
I put here like like dubious now I got
away everything was not was not good
here in a bad patient it's much easier
to give it by the to explain another
move but in this kind of questioning in
my opinion
many you have like extra pony and to
pass porn the queen son so everything
should be quite easy the icon c5 if he
takes with a poem you put night on c4
and here of course it makes it much
easier the fact that you have the same
piece on the ball if it's like different
minor pieces you may have some kind of a
chain but if it's the same minor pieces
it makes the picture even easier that's
why they say that the the night endings
I like Paul endings why they say then
because late the Knights have a special
feature they can win a temple now so
that's why you know it has like this
kind of a character like like the pawn
ending so take your night ecstasy 525
Queen D 394 well here if he pushes efore
it even includes you know the motive
that the Queen may not be defended non
d3 for example if you play here you have
to be careful of the rotation c5 so it's
not making your position strong it make
it even more vulnerable although it's
not it's not need like great efforts
anymore well I taught that but maybe
that's why it ended very badly so 96 a
good move like I said here in my
comments I have a two-part poem an extra
an extra pawn in total and no try to top
so everything is going fine and of
course we under on the 23rd move so no
kind of a time travel no and no way even
at the end you get less time than me
when bad things started to happen so II
for Queen h5 good g7
now even the pin is a problem for King
know so not not only all these factors
which which we have mentioned but even
take as a pin on the till I know it is
if it needed like another problem no now
King Jeeto because a he has to to
consider some time you know if I like if
you place
Queen f4 I can push it five no not very
pleasant 'if I've d5 and now the most
easiest move oh not the only one but he
okay doing the game I didn't even
consider maybe four seconds right to
give him you know such a such a bad
pitching why to give him such a chance
so so be aware in a such a favor of
question not to give him this kind of a
lackey changes like 94 and to give him
like this d6 no now if it takes in c5
you know he can take on c5 d7 another
Queen appears of course it's not it's
not needed for you until dead but still
you know you have everything under
control and suddenly because you know
you're playing one careless move anyway
this kind of mistakes when you have time
he's not you know and there is no need
to move the knight of d6 not the block
piece usually has a very good effect now
why to move it and to create some kind
of dynamics in the position so no need
at all so I play f5 even my queen now
becomes more active so everything seems
that the game is all we taste queen
takes from a fight no play at all now
even today looking at the at this game
it it gives me very very bad sensation
so every Queen g6 well now I thought all
the we're at the 28th move and I repeat
this a team competition and I'm a very
important at the most important match
and in the decision from but I really
doing the edit or maybe he'll resign I
didn't see a move I really couldn't see
a move here I mean you're tackling
everything
you're turning f4 you're threatening
even Queen takes from g3 so I thought
okay I mean okay so probably he'll
congratulate me and and I get like after
few moves you say ah I kept 2012 means
help two minutes so here probably I get
like 20 minute or something the way I I
really didn't see what white will play
but you don't have to to get into this
kind of a situation when you start you
know enjoying so much your position then
you know you're not concentrated
although he I have not lost my
concentration the next the next move is
really a big level although the
objectively the best move in the
pollution and I thought that this is the
best move but still it's a very
impractical decision so in this one when
I couldn't see a single move now you can
he can take when I fight no because
Knight takes on f5 no everything is
hanging here basically no move so he
plays my d3 and here I start thinking
and I still know that I don't have
expansion why I didn't played a very
very simple move because I saw here that
okay there is this very simple endgame I
mean simple is even stretching you know
you can play F oh no it doesn't matter
if he plays Queen e1 we need to you just
take take oh just one detail and this I
saw during the game okay please probably
everyone will see because it's there is
no lines no if it takes with the with a
knight the rukon b1 is hanging you can
take even Knight takes from evil not
that you needed it but okay it's it's
helping no so it because all of your
peers are better no just to show it on
the broad 91 you can even take you
although you don't even need that don't
know why not to take everything so takes
here you exchange in the game is over
you have to pass pause okay here I gave
lion okay you don't need lies you know
that this end game is if you are playing
a upon ending and you have to connect it
passed pawns so this is the game is over
your team qualifies and also to lose
such a game even now as you can imagine
what kind of feeling is after the game
if after so many years like how much
it's not now 12 years I still have very
bad memories about this game so instead
of that I said no no I'm going to play
like the move which i think is giving
checkmate no and it's really winning
immediately but still it's a impractical
decision so I gave him check rook Seto
and this is the best move but a very bad
okay this also happens in chest no not
the only move also taking here was okay
but away no need to to calculate like
many life if you see one line which
clearly
is go for this line and if it's an
endgame like this one go for this one
no need to give him checkmate because
not only they don't give you more than
one point for a victory but you're
putting you know sometimes it doesn't
matter it's a team completion on maybe
individual you're putting yourself at a
minimum reason I have something which I
forgot here so I tried you know to play
for for an attack and okay let's see how
it finished
check-check king h3 so here I get here I
see in my notes I have 12 minutes
against two of my opponent and suddenly
because it needs a little bit of
calculation although very easy one I
started making incredible mistakes and I
started having some kind of mirages so
first of all I don't play the simplest
taken info so after Knight takes me five
you just give check you know on f5 in
the game is over so he has to take here
let's go back a little bit he has to go
he has to take with a pole before you
take Knight takes e4 and basically there
is nothing to calculate here here and
the knight it denied dosqueen g4 is a
checkmate by the way maybe in my state
this was a little bit too complex for me
so I told it okay there is like a easier
move Knight takes me fall and I saw
exactly what happened in the game
so I told after 94 he has to play rubgy
1 this is what was my my way of thinking
and who you are and I told it here he
doesn't get any kind of threat because
in my way of thinking I said to you is
he's threatening something no I can even
defend my pawn on e5 because he can take
my knife because queen g4 and checkmate
if he plays g4 and he takes even away
five well I'll play Knight of - and I'm
still winning and this was like a
complete complete Mirage and because of
that you'll see in the end well here of
course there was like h5 quite strong
with the same motive because it's very
deep
to defend to defend he all night no
because if you go back
Quincy fall is some kind of a smoother
checkmate but maybe it was too complex
for me in my state of mind this is also
quite easily winning but neglecting that
he he can get any kind of thread because
probably okay the course of the game
makes you feel that way and not only
make making complete blunders but you
start feeling that okay you are playing
on only by yourself there is no opponent
so he doesn't have any any kind of
threats so that's why I play at six
which is like a big mistake
and after f6 he plays g4 and he starts
the panic because suddenly I see that if
I play like h5 which I paint to say let
me show you
he takes here a note night here he just
takes it and I can resign so okay now of
course I start having less time and I'm
starting you know missing almost
everything and I could have played here
move like different move but okay
h6 was a very bad move and it has to do
with the previous calculation just let
me show you here I can see that such a
move this is the so called remaining
image I can tilt rook to e3 and I
thought if it's quite good I thought
it's winning because on Knight takes
Rooney right you have Queen f5 check now
this intermediate check and I concealed
some lines and I thought okay maybe I
have something even easier because like
I told you earlier I was not aware that
after g4 you know he's threatening to
take on a fight and I don't get native
to so I even considered that which
should be like not too difficult win a
too complex and I thought okay I can
permit myself the line 3 to play at six
after I played the f6 and I saw that
I've missed a very very simple thing I
still had the hook on c3 like in the
previous line after playing route III so
this explains like the next move which
is like the end of this very very tragic
game but it has to do you know with a
sort of a panic with a sort of a
complete disbelieve that how this can
happen
to me how such a incredible pushin can
turn out so in my mind my rook was on c3
so that's why I play here already in
time travel I probably have seconds here
I play the end of you know this tragedy
f4 he just takes here and now I saw that
I can take the knight in d3 because the
work is not on c3 no and okay then of
course what follows is a very painful
loss in a very important game anyway he
is you know just accepting the accepting
the defeat and yes still nowadays if I
look at the end of this game it's it's
really giving me a lot of bad memory but
it's like nowadays when I look at it
it's not like a very desert loss because
hey you don't have to be impractical
during a chess game you have to you know
just to try to remember that okay
the end of the game is very important
for you and it it's not any different
than if you give checkmate or you just
win the game it's always one point so
you have to be a little bit more
practical and just not to to complicate
your life because then even you know
incredible mistakes game it's very
painful but okay I had to live with it
and I find it on the next year just to
be able to help the team so thank you
for being here with me and to share with
you this memory of mine and you see that
okay when the years progressed and in
the last you know when I'm not active
anymore
well more painful of this followed
because okay when you're not active you
start missing things which is so just
like every other game it needs it needs
to play constantly because if not you're
starting losing the habits
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]